[Music]
belts have been worn with different
types of garments since the invention of
clothes Maeda since your waistline this
accessory is worn with pants shirts
robes or dresses making a fashionable
addition to any outfit durable and
flexible leather is a classic material
used for belt making this production
facility manufacturers stylish
high-quality belts at top speed a
[Music]
designer creates a belt pattern on her
computer and sends the design
electronically to the in-house laser
etching machine a craftsman places a
cowhide on a large table he examines the
hide for any flaws and carefully marks
each one the cowhides are made from meat
industry byproducts and most are sourced
from Italy a device scans the shape of
the hide and the craftsman digitally
marks the location of the flaws a
specialized cutting machine uses the
marked information to create an
efficient series of cuts this process
results in a high quality product with
minimal waste another technician sorts
the various belt lengths into containers
preparing them for the next step the
cutting machine is capable of slicing up
to 2,400 belts per day the cutting
machine creates straight sharp edged
strips the technician feeds the belts
into a machine that bevels the edges at
the rate of 6,000 per day at the next
station a series of small suction
devices quickly lift and place each belt
on a conveyor system
a stamping machine accurately cuts the
shape of the belt tip and the holes for
the prom
[Music]
the craftsman stacks a group of belts
and packs them tightly together then he
dies the edges with ink and sands them
down these steps complement the edge
dyeing machine process which can add
color to the belt edges then the belts
are transferred to a drying machine the
edges must be completely dry before they
move to the next step
powered by World War 2 Jeep engines a
rotating wooden drum tumbles the belts
while simultaneously burnishing the
leather this type of machinery comes
from Italy's famous leather working
region this imported machine from Milan
rapidly punches out the pattern of
perforations which make up the belt
signature design elements since the
machines dye is less than 20 inches long
the complex pattern along the belt can't
be stamped at once instead the machine
punches out a section at a time
resulting in a production rate of 1400
belts per day a laser etching machine
burns a second pattern into the leather
surface this pattern was created by the
designer prior to production at the next
station a craftswoman fills the holes of
a specially crafted two-part metal die
with nail heads the nail heads are made
of zinc with a brass finish using a
press an operator places the die in a
waiting repository she removes the top
half ensuring that all of the holes are
filled with nail heads then she turns
the belt around and places it over the
die before sliding the belt inside the
press the press fixes the nail heads to
the leather
before attaching the buckle the belts go
through a process called skimming this
device shaves off a section of the
leather so that when it's folded over it
won't be too thick a loop is attached to
the end of the belt followed by a buckle
the craftswoman uses the loop to
temporarily hold the buckle and tag in
place the tag contains the belt size
price and brand information another
craftswoman sews the belt buckle and tag
in place using 69 weight thread and a
bar tacking stitch this facility
manufactures nearly 10,000 belts per day
this intricate leather fashion accessory
might be a cinch to wear but not to make